so i want to ask you the most important
question um i think that hugh jackman
might be the nicest person i've
interviewed in hollywood he's the best
have you ever actually seen him get
upset over anything
i don't think so i don't think so but i
will tell you about hugh he can have
quite a body sense of humor and
he can tell some kind of sexy joke
sometimes which surprised me because
he's so
gallant all of the time and uh and had
me in stitches i definitely haven't
heard him do this before now i'm very
curious yeah no but i just think it's
important that because
he's just such a nice guy he's just the
best and i just want to sort of throw
that out there that people realize that
i i you know hugh is
um
very quietly
uh just the most decent and supportive
guy you know i i
as a
first time
director
female wanting to do something original
that's hard for anyone to get off the
ground
and hugh in leveraging his
you know
movie star status to really support me
completely even before i had financing
um or the backing of a studio
that is a testament to his his goodness
and his
earnestness when he believes in
something
you know the the interesting thing about
hugh though is
he's so nice but his niceness doesn't
come from
being purely
pleasant to people it's not a simple
niceness it is so
well and deeply considered i don't think
i've ever seen somebody who studies
human beings more than you whenever i
look at him i can see his mind working
he notices everything every micro
gesture of every single person on crew
he remembers every single name and he
processes everything and i think that's
why he's so good
at playing
different characters because he's such
an astute observer of human nature i was
so impressed by that when we spoke last
time we talked a little bit about
editing but i i don't believe i was able
to ask you about like did you end up
with a lot of deleted scenes like how
did this film change in the editing room
um well i you know i tend to
know
a lot about how how i want the movie to
look in the end so no there were not a
lot of deleted scenes um
things get trimmed and air compressed
out of it but
when you're also the writer and it's
lived with you for so long um you know
whenever i work on something i tend to
know how i want it to look in the
in the end now that's not to say that
mark yoshikawa my editor who is genius
didn't find flourishes and moments
and little workarounds for difficult
spots that that were
totally inspired i mean i think his edit
took the film
uh to to a new level and uh corrected
any mistakes i may have made as a writer
i am so curious about the fallout series
and if you don't mind me asking what can
you tease people about it i mean it is
just a gonzo crazy funny
just
adventure
and mind [ __ ] like none you've ever seen
before it's it's pretty cool
everything you everything you just said
sounds amazing i already have to go i'm
just gonna say again congrats i am so
happy to help you support the movie
thank you so much it was so good seeing
you again i feel like we're all friends
now let's you know come again at the uh
after at the end of this
absolutely good luck with the rest of
your interviews thank you